Listing all the ways Avengers: Endgame made
us emotional would take forever.
Instead, we'll focus on just one spoiler-ridden
aspect of the superhero ensemble that packed
a heart-rending punch: the line little Morgan
Stark told her father, Tony, early on in the
film, and the same one he repeated back to
her at the end.
Reportedly, Avengers: Endgame directors Joe
and Anthony Russo sat down with Watching Hollywood
and explained the origins of the adorable
and impactful line.
Translated to English by the folks at ComicBook.com,
the interview details that the "I love you
3,000" line came about from Tony Stark actor
Robert Downey Jr.
The actor told the Russo brothers that one
of his three children told him they loved
him that much, and the directors found the
story so sweet that they couldn't resist incorporating
the line into Endgame twice.
Since this explanation is said to have come
straight from the people in charge, it effectively
shuts down all other speculation fans stirred
up around the "I love you 3,000" line.
Some theorized that the phrase Morgan told
her father may have been a clever comeback
to him mentioning "tons" when he told her
how much he loved her.
One U.S. ton equals 2,000 pounds — and 3,000
is a bit more than that figure.
Another idea Marvelites had was that the "3,000"
of the phrase is actually a nod to the Marvel
Cinematic Universe, as 3,000 is the combined
number of minutes every already-released movie
and the yet-to-launch Spider-Man: Far From
Home run for.
Figures from IMDb pin the MCU thus far — from
Iron Man to Avengers: Endgame — as running
for a total of 2,867 minutes.
Assuming that Spider-Man: Far From Home will
match the 133-minute runtime of Spider-Man:
Homecoming, that brings the number up to 3,000.
"I love you 3,000" was one of two unforgettable
lines Tony Stark gave in Avengers: Endgame.
The other came at the climax.
After Tony retrieves the Infinity Stones from
Thanos and locks them into his own suit, the
Mad Titan says, "I am inevitable."
Thanos snaps his fingers, then looks shocked
to see Tony wielding the Infinity Stones.
Just as Thanos' line mirrors what he told
the surviving Avengers at the start of Endgame,
Tony gives an equally memorable callback when
he says "I am Iron Man."
"The truth is…
I am Iron Man."
While "I love you 3,000" was apparently thought
out in advance, "I am Iron Man" was a snap
decision.
The Russo brothers admitted during a Q&A session
for Avengers: Endgame that Tony's powerful
moment in the film wasn't included in the
script — and didn't even make it into the
movie until the filmmakers were editing.
According to the Russos:
"Tony used to not say anything in that moment.
And we were in the editing room going, 'He
has to say something.
This a character who has lived and died by
quips.'
And we just couldn't, we tried a million different
last lines.
Thanos was saying, 'I am inevitable.'
And our editor Jeff Ford […] said, 'Why
don't we just go full circle with it and say
I am Iron Man?'"
Tony Stark began the MCU as we know it with
Iron Man, and he ended the franchise's 11-year
saga with Avengers: Endgame.
His character arc finally came to an emotional
close when he bravely sacrificed his life
to ensure the safety of the entire universe.
It's only right that he was the messenger
of some of the hardest-hitting lines in the
film, and the hero who likely made audiences
openly weep in their theater seats.
Though he's gone for good, it's clear that
fans will always love him…
3,000.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.